the raiders uh 2-0 and potentially on
the way to
uh the 16-0 season that we heard uh
we heard proclaimed uh uh on twitter do
we get that one more time mr freeman
it's 16 and almost 16-0 man
that's right the man who brought that to
us delightfully on twitter
with the raiders being two and all we
had to get caliendo on the show
are you there frank you know you have no
idea how many people
are are talking to me today or trying to
is that right
oh it's great it's crazy because of that
well not not just because of last night
the mask was halfway on gruden you just
want to go what what are you doing i got
a visor on man it's invisible
you ever wear an invisible visorizing
they're going to try and find me rich
they can't find find this rich i'll tell
you what man
that's tremendous stuff i got belichick
next week i'm shutting them down man
well i mean if you want if you want to
talk about it belichick was
first of all i think he put his mask on
initially upside down
okay he had it folded under you're going
to fold it
i know and then like a bird man
[Music]
he's talking to invisible people man
that's like my invisible visor
you know what we did after the game we
made a tick-tock
rich that's what we did head shoulders
knees and toes tic tac
i'm going viral man literally literally
because i didn't wear my mask yeah and
afterwards he said
apparently apparently he had uh he had
the virus he said he says he takes it
seriously and then he apologized but uh
man he's
he is too you know did you read did you
reach out to him after the game last
night
uh i texted him last night he got back
to me this morning he just said thanks
last week i sent him a video that was he
so they
after that win he got back to me quit
pretty quick last week
he says send me a video man i need a
video this thing this thing's killing me
man send me a video
so i sent him a video of uh
of asking hey where was cleveland
farrell man anybody know where he was
they i didn't see him for 59 minutes and
40 seconds and
then bang he's winning the game for us
man you know where he was gunther
because i had no idea man and uh
i guess that's what you said you tell me
they're using those for motivation
are you serious i just messaged with uh
actually this is my name dropping
segments my message with uh
i've become pretty good friends with
these guys as much as some idiot like me
can be friends with these guys
right but um i messaged derek carr today
and he got back to me right away too i
think they do see me as a little bit of
a good luck charm
but um i said i'm going to make a video
and i'm going to do this this week
of gruden just telling everybody keep
disrespecting derek carr
he's only having decent games he's never
going to be that good
let's see if you can rile him up a
little bit and keep them going here man
derek carr
average quarterback we're looking for
somebody else man
well he can't by the way you need to
find someone in your life who loves
uh loves you as much as gruden loves
nathan peter man
that guy is always
he doesn't even need a cape man peter
man
he's always gonna have a gig as long as
griffin's got a gig nathan peterman will
have a gig
as long as gruden's got one i love this
guy
man you should see you should see when
he's not in his superhero costume that's
even better man
well look man but it is a better league
for
when gruden's winning i i and and and if
the raiders are 2-0
and sitting there in vegas and gruden's
dialing it up i think
that you know you're going to get a lot
more phone calls frank
i would be yeah i mean it's awesome i
mean i he's been great to me
gruden has been great to me mayak
completely ignores me
but uh i know the feeling frank i know
the feeling don't worry
and on live television too i've done
that on live television so
so don't worry i know i know deep down
i mean deep down though mayor finds it
funny the last time mayok laughed at
laughed out loud in anything pop culture
with stripes but deep down
he finds it funny know it yeah
they're great they they you know when i
visited the team last year
i saw the momentum switch or the you
know the uh
energy switch from the year before i
visited that team and spoke to the team
yes
uh you know two years ago and i just
felt like ah
i don't you know it was it there wasn't
it was it was it was tough
and you know they were in the middle
season they were in arizona and they
actually won that game and gruden sent
me the game ball
afterwards and then i did another i did
the thing last year with them for hard
knocks
and the energy in that room was
completely different and you could just
feel
something starting to build and they
lost some tough close games last year
those the games that they won
the first two games of the season this
year that they won you know i feel like
they would have lost them last year in
the last second
so it's it's time you know once you get
to learn how to win
you got a chance to get on a hot streak
and you never know you know going
against belichick what do you what
listen we're going to just use a couple
of jedi mind tricks i'm actually a seth
don't worry about it we'll see what
happens i've got a cam newton they can
now throw or run
hey can somebody give me a favor and cut
steve's hair my son has an
interesting haircut okay thanks
only the raiders could look at steve
belichick's hair and go
i don't know it's not that bad
it is the battle of the haircuts and the
mask wearing next week
with new england in la and las vegas oh
man
uh thanks for the time frank you're the
best we'll chat soon
yeah you be well good to talk to you
right back at you
that's frank caliendo the best love when
frank's on knock on wood when you're if
you're with me
frank's on a different way 16-0 man
all right let's see peter man
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here